[Music]
the early 2000s what a fun time some of
you may not have been born yet it was a
heyday of mine all my friends from
college were living in new york
we all would congregate at a place
called don hills oh man on spring and
greenwich in new york city so much fun
dancing we would just dance to
sweaty messes and um it's what i was
introduced to a lot of music that i had
never heard bands like pulp and james
and paul kind of paul wants to make fun
of me
pulp yeah common people i love that song
i think that's the first time i heard it
was there and um oh there were a lot of
nyu students but then you'd see like
there'd be some fancy people there uh
kirsten dunst used to go there dance all
the time with her friends were you
intrigued by her i certainly was but i
couldn't get really close because there
was a wall of her girlfriends dancing
around her um and as always tell donna
and i not the name drop but we used to
dance together all the too late i know
but back then it wasn't name dropping it
was just zoe from don hills and we had
so much fun dancing and uh living it up
being young and carefree and i remember
one of those songs that i was introduced
to god was it good um
california
california christian's grimace
shivers i loved it though it was phantom
planet i was like
what is this song and everyone went nuts
and they started dancing and it was
really anesthetic but when i think of
that song i think of uh that place and
that time in my life which was really
one i'll cherish forever and now you all
know about it so uh is it gross the way
i saying that
not gross just
embarrassing embarrassing yeah it was
embarrassing what you were doing with
your house because i could tell you were
a little embarrassed to do it
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your nostalgic and slightly embarrassed
host justin long life could be a dream
sweetheart
with me as always
he's popping his head
yeah the phone yeah yeah well it's it's
uh a kind of obnoxious song to sing
poorly you know it's a really obnoxious
song
california yeah and now that song is so
um familiar to so many people because
it was uh
later used as the theme song for a hit
show called the oc
or the ock if you were our parents yes
that's how they pronounce it stands for
orange county oh yes and
it was a hit show created by josh
schwartz i believe yes i don't know oh i
think it was well i know it's a hit show
yeah oh am i thinking gossip girl it's
josh schwartz one of them was josh ward
he's hit maker of some sort and that
song was written by phantom planet uh
alex greenwald i think was the singer
and uh a wonderful actor a friend of
ours hopefully future friend of the show
jason schwartzman yeah was the drummer
he was the drummer that's right and um
man schwartzman's a great musician he
had that other song i loved uh coconut
records was greyed out he's the
renaissance man why are we talking about
the oc or the ock or the can that and a
time in your life where like the world
was your oyster and everything was was
right at your feet i'll tell you why why
because our guest today was one of the
stars of the show
california
you you're a little bit like who's the
muppet um
oh like far out you sing a little like
janine you look a little bit like oh
okay well thank you california our guest
today is adam brody yes adam uh the
delightful isn't he delightful he's just
a puckish
uh
smart fun guy to talk to i've never met
him nor have you heard him yeah i
haven't and you guys haven't heard i'm
sure many of you are familiar with him
as we said how many times we're gonna
say it he's the star of the oc um but
he's done many movies since then uh he
was in grind with our friend joey kern
and
uh he was in a movie with me called yoga
hosers that maybe six of you have seen
right now he's in a movie
called promising young woman which is a
fantastic movie i just saw it on a plane
a few weeks ago she shouldn't have seen
that i mean
i saw tennant on a plane it was so good
yeah promising young woman god is a
great with um hopefully future guest
yeah kerry mulligan friend uh and
hopefully friend of the show carrie
mulligan adam brody is great knit uh
it's a great um
a lot of ensemble a lot of men
are in it uh
you could have been in it yeah you don't
rub it in um but you weren't yeah thanks
a lot emerald fennel what a great name a
hell of a director uh this movie's so
good you got to see it but i love the
way they use adam in the movie don't you
that it kind of plays
against his
i would guess nice guy persona we talk
about it he also stars and produced a
movie which got excellent reviews i've
not seen it yet called the kid detective
i think it's just kid detective it's the
kid detective it is i'm sorry god it's
all right i still can't get over how
adamant i was adam and i was about uh
jessica rabbit in her feet
still thinking about that wow a couple
weeks ago you're usually not that um i
know
that that's that's why and now you'll
end up being wrong about it usually when
you're that convicted about something
you're right well now i'll be even less
convicted about something that up well
that's good it's it's not good
no at all no i know i know it's not good
to be that sure of yourself a memory
from the of a movie you haven't seen in
20 years i just wonder what you should
never be that sure of yourself that's
true i know that was strange that i
really like stuck to my guns on that um
anyway speaking of sticking to your guns
uh adam was also in mr and mrs smith oh
how about that pretty good segway those
two stuck to their guns in that movie is
it fair to say and thank you for smoking
uh-huh oh i thought you were saying that
to me uh he's been in a lot he's been a
lot a lot of stuff a lot of great work
uh adam is a very natural actor he's
very off the cuff he and we talk about
it with his some of that dialogue he had
in the oc was
kind of dense that stuff that t some of
that tv writing it was a little bit like
dawson's creepy yes it was it certainly
was it was uh came out a couple of years
after that right maybe three years yeah
yeah and it was a time again we talk
about but just for some context for our
younger listeners uh it was a time where
there were a ton of uh teen shows there
was a teen boom in hollywood and uh
that's how i got my start and a lot of
other young actors it was a good time to
be a young actor and adam uh was one of
those guys that came out of that time
and he's he's continuing to thrive he's
got a new family with another uh
wonderful young actor uh leighton
meester hopefully a future guest yes a
friend another friend who is yet to be a
friend of the show it's a theme so far
in this introduction but uh let's get
into it yes please here we go this is
adam brody
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
[Music]
no you're not allowed to be early i'm
always early are you really yeah
compulsive exactly no that's how i do it
well does it automatic is it a power
move
no it's absolutely not it's not at all
i don't know it's like well i'm going to
be on time i'm good at that wow if i'm
going to be at the time it's hard to
like get there at the exact minute all
right
[ __ ] i may as well be five minutes
early everywhere i go and that is
whatever that's so admirable adam i wish
i clayton's the opposite oh really well
it's it's in her name but uh yeah
it makes sense she's an actor so the
truth is
we have jobs that we can't really be
that late for i mean some people i know
i mean she's a high functioning adult
you know like
so
and in many ways more so than me you
know i mean she's more self-reliant i
think than i am
you guys have very different
background i mean very different
upbringings yeah yeah yeah mine's like
pretty mean potatoes and hers is insane
yeah what's the opposite of meat and
potatoes if it's in food wise is it like
oh yeah right uh i guess like
fusion some kind of crazy fusion but
fusion that doesn't go together like
yeah i don't know a failed a failed
fusion kosher
sushi is out of um
yeah uh but yours was saying so yours
was san diego i i always assumed i
didn't know that until i
did some research my brother did some
research deep dive yeah a deep dive and
do people usually assume that you are
that from an area like that it makes
sense to me now
it depends what season of life i'm in i
guess but there was a moment there where
people then started to assume
grew up and was very much a surfer
and even though you know my parents were
are jewish i'm jewish although nobody's
religious i um didn't feel i didn't have
any i didn't know any other jewish
people i didn't have any kinship with it
did they raise you with the religion at
all like not they never said the word
god like ever but um they made me go to
hebrew school which i was so pissed
about you know i just found to be like
beyond tedious on sunday i got to go
downtown
instead of doing whatever my friends are
doing and then you know and then get
made fun of for it like a lot really
yeah not in a way that ever bothered me
it really didn't and i think it was good
natured enough even though the [ __ ] that
was said was pretty mean it was from my
friends who did like me so it was yeah
oh okay you know an otherness a ribbing
it was affectionate anti-semitism just
exactly right yeah
um that's exactly what it was were there
not a lot of jewish kids in san diego
not in my suburbs you know not in my
school i knew like two um and then i was
surfing and not surfing either um not at
the beach which i didn't grow up at the
beach so that was another click and then
uh and then i moved to la and i kind of
was like
[ __ ] it i don't want to be a surfer i
just like more or less my 20th birthday
i decided to you know track and i was 19
and real also you didn't do plays or
anything no
wow and then i was like oh i i want to
be
an actor and i'm a little embarrassed of
this like
dudeness
and i'm uninterested right now now
there's a whole new world opening up i
wasn't even like reading books in high
school i was a bad student not you know
just because i wasn't inspired so what
was it about acting that that why why
did you decide
to try it a little bit part
directionless and yeah
and then also
i did you know i can look back and
realize like oh i had an interest for a
long time even though i never pursued it
like it always
spoke to me a little bit randomly i was
you know when i graduated high school i
moved out i was working at blockbuster
videos so i was sort of absorbing a lot
of movies then i didn't work for a long
time there but like a year for our
younger listeners that was a um
that was an establishment where they
rented and sold uh isn't that crazy i
mean how obsolete that sounds now how
how how archaic it's so bananas i love
blockbuster which you worked at one in
la san diego oh oh at the san diego one
yeah so you love movies you like being
around movies and stuff yeah and i was
getting particularly into it then i mean
who doesn't first of all i mean it's
it's like everyone likes a movie but i
just
um i got into it a little more then and
then coincidentally my roommate had a
friend who was also like an ex-surfer
who moved to l.a with his mom and
started acting and dabbling and we're
like let's go up for 48 hours and see
what that's like and what his life is
like and then we're into it and we're
like let's come back in a month and just
move up here and just see and i moved up
on a whim to just
try and throw myself head headlong head
first into uh acting and and see what
happened and then and i would have
turned back pretty quickly if i didn't
get any traction but fortunately i did
really i was gonna say yeah how long do
you think you would have given it i mean
it's tough it's tough to say because
it's a sliding scale of you know
i as long as i saw progress you know i i
don't know you know in that level of
what i might my floor of what i would
require as progress or success goes up
every had gone up every year but yeah
well how quickly did it then happen
remarkably fast remarkably fast i mean
it felt long at the time it still sounds
crazy to me now i moved up at my on
basically my 19th birthday i had no sad
card no experience never taken an acting
class nothing and no real connections
either i spent my 20th birthday i
celebrated it on the paramount lot as
the lead of like a behind the scenes
brady brunch tv movie oh my god it was
cool it was unbelievable i was driving
through the paramount gates like every
day for a month as the lead of this
movie um
i remember that feeling that um
specifically at paramount because it
felt so like what you think of as
hollywood you know it felt like it was
almost like
cliche it was like oh the alien extras
smoking cigarettes you park in the lot
where it's like the big wall that's
painted like the sky yep like you know
truman show at edge and true or
something it wasn't like that changed
everything i mean what it did allow me
to do i had a string of part-time jobs
that year and then i never had to have
another part-time job after that i was
just an actor it didn't like really
change anything for me and then i then i
was unemployed again for the next three
four months and i didn't know anyone and
it was still like a lonely existence for
a handful of years but
it did feel like
and the other thing that was so cool was
like randomly i don't know why but they
also had like a premiere for it at a
movie theater so like four months six
months after that i invited my parents
up who were like skeptical of me going
to be an actor rightly so because i had
never done it
like a year and a half later i'm like
come to my movie and and it's it's
commonly known that jews never succeed
in hollywood yes that's exactly right
and that's why i had to fight a lot of
stigma
um well
well adam also must have been like
i know that feeling too which is like
they have this fear about you doing this
thing that is very untenuous and like
that now there's they see you at a
premiere so it's like it validates this
uh crazy thing that you're doing that
must have felt really good too it felt
great and it's not that they were ever
like they were always hopeful and very
supportive but you know it they changed
my dad particularly right it was funny
it was like
we had such a contentious high school
relationship and junior high
and like vanished over you know i mean
it's like all right you're offered you
got it you never mind what do i know you
figured it out yeah oh my god like we've
been good ever since and so out of that
the root of that contentiousness was
that you were kind of
wayward and directionless he wanted you
to be more
stable like yeah i mean the root of it
was almost as simple as like my grades
weren't good enough
why can't you just get [ __ ] decent
grades
and i'm like i just
i don't know i just don't think i can i
just uh did you go to college i didn't
go i did i did for two years and then
i dropped out to try this but yeah
because i was gonna say that like we
also were very lucky in that um i think
we're like a similar age and
a
i'm oh i'm 64. oh
um i'm 42. uh
yeah yeah but that time i remember like
there were you know it was just a great
time to be actors rh and to like
well i was going to ask you i don't have
a i only have a guest but i don't have a
sense of it because i'm not watching the
uh the high school college stuff now but
still it feels like that was a golden
era
for
you know high school content
and um and of course being a young white
man didn't didn't hurt yeah either um
but
yeah it just felt like i was moving up
there in the era
up here in the era of american pie and
freddy prince jr and you know it was all
that it was it was that time i don't
think you're wrong at all i think anyone
would say that um except maybe young
people now
would say no no no this is the best time
for yeah yeah yeah yeah i know it was it
was that era and there were so many
and we both benefited from that and and
uh certainly when you got the oc or even
before the gilmore girls there was an
arc on the gilmore girls that kind of
led to the oc right i don't think they
directly related to each other but i did
go from that
to the other and i felt like even at the
time
with the oc like
you know i was 23 and i did feel like a
veteran you know i really did by that
time you know i was actually quite i
don't think i was cocky i was just
confident and i knew the kind of
lay of the land and i felt like i kind
of knew my
ability and and and uh
yeah i wondered that you you've always
had a very natural you always seemed
very natural with with dialogue that
sometimes felt like it might trip
other actors up if that makes sense i
think that's probably my strongest skill
set you know i mean i think like
like going deep digging deep getting
real into character
brooding that has never been my strong
suit but if you got a speech like i can
wrap my and and the language is tricky i
can probably figure that out did that do
were you ever did you ever deal with
nerves did you ever deal with um did you
ever read something and think i'm not
going to be able to
ground this this is i can't say this i
uh
were you nervous as when you started out
i mean of course still nervous you know
i mean i always i uh sometimes before i
go do something now i'm like i can't
believe i do this i can't believe i
able to do this and i don't know how i'm
gonna do this and what a wild job
but um i remember just going back to
that brady bunch movie for a minute like
being feeling like you get older and you
learn you learn how to face out to
camera and you learn how to but i had so
much trouble
in that first job i was still the whole
thing was like [ __ ] a choice it was
about like how do i even be natural how
can i even sound like human is so much
of it and then and then all the you know
if you're making something funny that's
fun and that actually did come natural
and was fun but it was like a fear of
not being able to make stuff sound
natural and so
any time that was my first real you know
i had been on tv for like us you know a
total of two minutes previous to that
and it was i was so defensive of like
you know they'd be like can you cheat
here can you hit this mark or can you
face out here and i'm like no i can't
because like it's not natural
i felt so
limited in my ability to uh even make it
natural at all that i couldn't possibly
also
hit an unnatural mark
out in an unnatural way i know what you
mean i know i always used to really
admire those actors i i worked with one
on a tv show this guy tom who could he
was so good about the props drinking on
a certain line putting it down without
interrupting a line
he did everything
and i remember at the time thinking
oh he's that's mechanical that's not
natural that's not but he had the skill
set to be able to
remember all those things that the
mechanical elements of the editing and
know when they were going to cut
and still be natural
and at the time i just thought well he's
not in it he's not like yeah yeah you
should just do whatever you know because
i had the same fear yeah that's what it
is it's a fear of being unnatural
when you got the oc was that did that
elevate your comfort level to a place
where you'd go to work and you were
excited honestly the oc i was pretty
confident by then i had done this show
it was a um very derivative of uh
american pie but we did it in vancouver
and i was one of the four leads and i
felt like wait what was it was called
the sausage factory maybe maybe
and then it was called it was called now
what when it ultimately played down here
oh funny and um and this was in like
2000
and 2000 maybe 2001 the sausage factory
the sausage factory henry pinka says the
sausage factory and um um anyways it was
a blast
and i felt like i got so much experience
from that you know being doing like a
jason biggs type thing for 13 episodes i
bet i felt like a veteran of like the
teen comedy by then anyway and um you
know it depended honestly if it was
lighter and comedic i felt very good and
very confident like um
the oc i felt really good gilmore girls
i felt really good i wasn't nervous at
all and then if it was dramatic i felt
much more out of my depth you know i did
like huh horrible guest stars on you
know procedural stuff
i mean you know that stuff really well
where you have to say like um police
jargon or like medical stuff no no where
i was like there's like a judging amy
episode i did this is before these other
jobs and like you're like a delinquent
i'm a goth kid
i've got like goth and i'm and i'm on
trial because my girlfriend and i wanted
to kill ourselves and we did but i
chickened out at the last moment and she
died oh it's like [ __ ] it's like
melodramatic stuff it's melodramatic
while i'm looked like the cure you know
robert yeah do a cure yeah and um and
i'm having a breakdown on the stands oh
man yeah it's have you seen that it's
not good have you seen it in a while oh
my god uh not in like 10 years and
certainly not the whole thing in 20 but
yeah i think i've seen like a clip of it
and i can't bear to it's i can't bear to
watch also i can't bear to watch that
that said despite any confidence i had i
also can't bear to watch any of voc or
oh really can i
speculate on something that i'm ninety
percent sure is right for you and it's
300 sure right for me
the first half of my 20 when i moved up
to la and so this is pretty much for
most of the oc certainly gilmore girl
certainly any of the stuff i did in my
like vince vaughn was my acting hero oh
my god yeah yeah and and
and to the point where i'm doing a
terrible invitation of him oh my god
it's so funny
most of my 20s
yeah and i've i've since knocked that
off
yeah that was you know a lot of my
acting for better and worse in my 20s is
adam i don't even think that's shameful
maybe i'm just saying that because i'm
so guilty of it um but i think i also
see other and i wonder if you do um
other very clear influences like uh i
see a lot of like guys that i looked up
to like sam rockwell and uh
michael j fox is there and who who are
some of those other do you ever pinpoint
you ever pinpoint like oh that's from
even if it's like a friend that i
thought was cool yeah these are gonna
sound weird but i have and it won't
trend it'll be silly sounding like i've
done them but i still can have a picture
in my head and i can filter it through
me and i swear i'd get something from it
but like i've pulled from like harrison
ford and tom cruise a couple of times
there's a line here and there yeah
has a great intent focused intensity yes
and harrison ford has a great i'm pissed
off at everyone like yeah there was a
man in my house yeah but just even like
pissed off it i mean it's sort of
archaic now but like mad at women for
nothing you know
when like
yeah when it was cool to have like be
mad at your leading lady for you know
right
right
yeah yeah to overreact that uh i'm
thinking of raiders of the lost ark now
like with karen allen jack
nicholson uh is in my head but i can't
say like i ever do a lot i never do like
a line reading of his stuff but i
i look to him a little bit and then i
also um
again i never really have done a line
i've never felt to me like i'm
consciously pulling like a nicholas cage
but i look to him too
what i like about him and jack nicholson
a little bit but nicholas cage is
he's pretty theatrical you know he's
pretty like he first of all he's just so
brilliantly funny but also can go so
deep and just be so real but but could
be so big and still
he's so big and he has fun with that and
i like that like gq uh
he explains his roles and i just love it
and he's just talking about like he's
not worried about being natural and he's
pulling from other things that are more
theatrical like paintings and [ __ ] yeah
like um and
old performances of like silent movie
stuff and and i just think that's so
neat yeah well that's why i've also
always loved michael richards um
from i don't know is that kramer kramer
yeah i i sometimes i just marvel at what
he does because it is so it's like
cartoonishly big but it is so it's all
real it's it's it's amazing that hum
like human behavior can be that big uh
because you never see that you rarely
see that in life but it's like he makes
it all real i feel that way about
nicholas cage too um
i i was doing i did like a handful of
episodes of the league
and jeff and jackie schaefer who ran
that also run um or jeff at least does
yeah curb your enthusiasm and i learned
pretty quickly on that like
oh it's just much better if i yell
everything like like
like sometimes subtlety works and i i've
gotten more subtle as i've gotten older
and i've learned more the power of
stillness and i do i do less as i get
older and it seems to work and i'll tell
you who else i've pulled from with no
one would ever think or you never
connected but like brad pitt is an
influence too and he can do [ __ ]
nothing and does a lot with his hands
i've seen him he's got cool hands and it
does a lot but yeah the guy just you
guys just choose food and whispers and
like talks with a with a karate chop
that's true that's true he punctuates
everything with his yeah
that's true do you when you look at the
oc uh you mentioned like you have a hard
time like watching that stuff is do you
ever um because i do this uh fixate on
your hands do you because i i think
oftentimes like gestures are a real tell
if somebody's not
if somebody's not comfortable or being
truthful you can see it in there i see
it on the when i watch reality shows and
guys who are uncomfortable and
it comes out in their hands do
you
you know when i think back on like
performances of mine i can't the the
body language doesn't come to mind so
much it's the voice
and and you know
uh yeah the oc is me like doing a
chipmunk vince vaughn i still feel like
i'm going for even though i'm mid-20s
like it sounds like i'm going through
puberty stuff i know me too i know i i
think i i it sounds like i'm forcing my
voice up when i watch old stuff but i uh
yeah i i think our voices have probably
just hopefully just naturally dropped
we've gone through puberty i think
almost a late puberty and and i think it
was that speed and that high vince
varnisms her
velocity and it just yeah i don't know i
just watch it now and i'm like settle
down
i know i know a lot of people who were
on shows that were massive like the oc
like those teen shows that were so big
can you talk about that like how quickly
that changed for you because it was such
a massive show so popular among
younger people that um
i i can only imagine what that must be
like i've never really experienced that
that degree of fame honestly like we
were in such a bubble it was pre-social
media so that's true we're filming down
in manhattan beach it wasn't like i had
yeah 20 million twitter followers or
whatever and i'm like i was like dating
my co-star everyone was dating someone
that knew what we were just in like a 30
person you know social bubble that it
felt like another planet too yeah at the
time and it was you know we're kind of
the only ones on that studio felt more
like office buildings or something is
that where they shot csi miami i don't
know about that but it's where they shot
ally mcbeal in boston public i know oh
okay all right i just didn't feel yes we
got more famous but i was living in
hollywood i wasn't around that many
places i mean and even the opportunities
like
i felt like at once oh my god i have all
these opportunities all of a sudden and
i'm seeing movies and i'm getting cool
meetings but we filmed that show like
nine nine and a half months a year it
wasn't much time to like capitalize on
it really
have you talked to because i know
leighton was on a similarly popular show
did you guys have similar experiences or
was hers more i think more
hers was more efficient hers was way
more public they were filming i think it
was first of all it was you know
later so there's more social media
there's more right even more paparazzi
there's more and then also they're
filming on the streets of new york which
is just oh yeah you know and and um yeah
so i mean while we were filming off on
our own
they were
on the street
it was like a it seemed like you know
trl or something like it
um we're just you know i mean that's one
of her complaints is like there'll just
be like fan you know fans and paparazzi
in your eye line and they wouldn't even
do enough seemingly to get them out of
there in fact maybe even kind of courted
it i don't know but like it was a real
scene and um i know that
that sounded hard and then also just the
fast-paced life of also being in your
very early 20s famous on a show in new
york oh my god yeah
[Music]
who hasn't been there you're standing in
the wine aisle staring at the shelves
even if i go in with a plan i find
myself getting overwhelmed by the
options there's that's why i don't like
those stores i also don't like wine
really but i do now i do now i started
drinking why well what changed your mind
i'm 43 now you know it's time i'm i'm an
adult and i discovered first leaf first
leaf is it's a much better way to
discover wine at a fraction of the price
you'll find in a store one of those
confusing wine stores so first leaf is
let's we should tell people what it is
it's it's a fully customizable wine club
that sends curated boxes of wine who
doesn't like being right
even if you don't like wine clubs are
fun do you know i've been part of the
club for a few months now i they
generously offered um us both to try the
club and i liked it so much
i remained a member you did yeah i'm up
to um
three months in now oh they got so
exciting every month they send you
a box of
wine that they curated it is exciting to
get those things because i have kind of
a bad memory so like it's it's a such a
surprise for me what's this box somebody
sent me a bunch of wine so save time
money and stress with first leaf it's
the wine club designed with you in mind
join today and you'll get six bottles of
wine for just 29.95
and free shipping just go to try first
leaf dot com slash long that's six
bottles of wine for 29.95 and free
shipping at try first leaf dot com slash
long life is short is generously
supported by the zebra how many times
have you ordered something silly online
christian uh you know i i'm pretty
prudent i'm pretty prudent but i've
definitely ordered things that i didn't
necessarily need but then there's you
know those big purchases like insurance
insurance is thing that you don't get to
see it's not tangible right away so it's
like kind of annoying to buy and i don't
know if you knew this but americans
overspend on car and home insurance by
billions each year billions
and that doesn't have to be you you can
avoid that how the zebra the zebra is
the nation's leading insurance
comparison site for car and home
insurance and in just minutes you can so
easily compare policies from every major
provider for free and here's the key
it's all on one independent marketplace
so they ask you a few questions very
simple the zebra then pairs people with
the right insurance company for their
specific needs so you save time you save
money and who doesn't want to save both
time and money man they're both pretty
precious and and the best thing about it
the key actually is that they have no
stake in the policy you choose they're
just they're just there they exist to
find the coverage that's right for you
so they're not leading you in any
direction that's right so you can buy it
online or over the phone with one of
their licensed insurance agents and
there are no hidden fees or fine print
about your personal information make
insurance your smartest purchase yet
visit the zebra.com
long to get your free quote today that's
the
zebra.com
long
hello hello again
[Music]
so you said you you were able to do
other barely able to do other things
while you were doing the oc was mr and
mrs smith and thank you for smoking
which i know were too those were two big
movies for you did they happen during
the oc or was it happened during and
those were like a few couple days shoots
for me each one was easy and uh mr smith
i um
doug lyman directed and he directed the
pilot of the oc which is the reason i
did that which is so back to vince
vaughn so
love vince vaughn saw swingers when i
was
in high school and it meant nothing to
me i didn't really get it you know um i
wasn't there yet i wasn't an actor and i
was like i don't know i saw and forgot i
don't think i hated it but i just didn't
land for me and then i moved to la and
then i was
lonely living in a dump in hollywood by
myself and like you know just lonely and
felt like this is i don't know and then
discovered that movie and then i'm like
not only is it like my favorite acting
but it's just glamorizing my life and i
want to be these people and watch it a
million times so then the oc i was
already
i was 23 so when i was on gilmore girls
i was reluctant to dive into a high
school show mostly just because of the
age of it all um i was like the cool
thing is to play your age i'm sure
you're very friendly
yeah yeah it took me a long time yeah
yeah um and and so i
was hesitant and he wasn't on board
first so i kind of declined like reading
for it i think and then
he
came on to direct and i also loved born
identity he had directed born identity
by then and go
but it was really the swingers of it all
you know he's just like he was my
favorite director i was like okay i'll
do you know i'll go report i'll do it
and then got the part and then he asked
me to do
mr smith i was very excited to do that
and then vince vaughn was in that and
then
him doug and i went to a screening like
he doug flew
vince and i to a screening in orange
county in his little prop plane so oh
that's number one so so you got to tell
vin you got to hang with him a bit yeah
i don't think i said any of this stuff
but um
a strange silent kid in the corner
uh
what um was coppo i know we both have
done um kevin smith's stuff yeah yeah
lot of comments
yeah yeah i mean like i think for life
now we kind of have to yeah yeah that's
right you get the call every two three
years
for better or for worse
it's honestly like they're the most fun
nice to wet so i just i get stoned you
give me a round of applause when i show
up i'll do whatever i want to encourage
you to show me playback we'll do like
two takes i'm out of there and then you
and i'll hang in your trailer for a
little like i know i know it's it's
pretty great um and kappa was the first
time popout was the first time saved for
like a quick
get out the vote commercial
a couple years before the kappa was a
blast he had a nightmare on it
that's right yeah uh
right all that bruce stuff he you know
people
come up to me somebody just did the
other day and they were like is working
with bruce i he's just put that out
there so many times that i don't i used
to hesitate to even mention it but he uh
yeah yeah he had a tough time what uh
was he so he was smoking then because i
i
when did he start i know he didn't used
to right
and then he once he started he did it as
you know yeah all day he really like hit
the ground running yeah i think he was
smoking then yeah uh-huh yeah
how often do you but you can't smoke
before you you do no i don't i mean i
probably could but i wouldn't you know
like me i'm curious to see what would
happen and i'm sure some stuff would be
interesting but like i would never you
know
i take that back i've been a little
stoned in something
and it was fine but i but i uh in
general
don't i
i got too too stoned in one thing i'll
tell you one this is uh it's way too
long a story but next time i run into
you it's a fun story um but i i will
never again because of that experience
yeah i i definitely would be
yeah
i just
i don't i don't know how he does it uh
but he does but he he's
you know i i do i feel like i could in a
if you're direct enough you're not like
you're always stoned but you're never
like
wasted and so you know it's not like a
tolerance it's not yeah he's not getting
like paranoid and then also
it's his set it's his comfort everything
that's true you know it's like it's your
environment so i could be i know that i
can be
creative and productive yeah to an
extent i mean i'll probably take a nap
in a few hours you know but like for a
few hours i'm pretty inspired do you do
you write do you
yeah
not nearly as much as i'd like to but i
have a blast every
two years when i'm in final draft
writing something it's like yeah
yeah the rest is just like spitballing
and that's fun too but i wish i was more
prolific or
driven
yeah me too well
baby
i'm sensing a threat but like you said i
mean like we said he he's able to do
both he he's
figured out a way and with kids it must
be
that much harder to have those
smoking times certainly but um
you can also
get to a pretty child you can do it
anyway but like you can get to a child
you can get on their level it might help
i was gonna say yeah yeah like there are
there are times i'm like all right you
want to play dolls let's play dogs
like i said you might be able to dive
deeper into dolls but you also have to
make sure not to burn the house down and
so all right to balance calibrate yeah
yeah you got to make sure you know at
least somebody is
not stoned around to turn off the oven
uh-huh how um
how have you guys been in quarantine
with the kids how was that well you know
we had another kid during this
quarantine oh wow
so
thank you
so it's been it's been mostly nice to
be forced to kind of okay well totally
he's seven months now the last trimester
of the pregnancy plus this we've been
home like it's been
that has been nice you know if we've
had less help because of it had less
distraction had less play dates for our
daughter so you know had less when my
wife was um
when leighton was you know very
uncomfortable in her last
uh
trimester you know she couldn't get any
like
you know i'd give her a massage but like
can get massage couldn't get any like
couldn't go to like
just couldn't really have any outside
support mentally or physically
and how is your daughter now um
oh wow my god
and you know maybe i'll be proven wrong
but i can tell already like they're
going to be close like they already
really like each other and
and she's so sweet nature
that and
he's going to be too that i i um
you know kids are kids are like
you meet a lot of kids as a as a anyone
does but as a parent and um
not all of them are nice
and kind and yeah you wonder
yeah and the funny thing is obviously
some of it's what is learned and what is
not and what is going to be a phase that
you're grown out of and what who's going
to be a dick for their whole life i know
and i it's a very interesting question
and i have that you know i'm thinking of
a few kids where i'm like your parents
are so nice
you're awful yeah we'll name them like
who would i
would i would i pair it differently yes
would i try to nip some of this in the
bud with some more consequences
absolutely but it still seems like some
of this is their nature and i wonder
are you always going to be a little are
you going to be a little backstabber or
are you going to grow out of this and
this is just uh
you know as adolescents trying for you
but you will adjust i'm definitely out
of my depth in talking about this but i
would imagine that um
isn't that kind of who you are i mean
are don't they say that don't they say
you're formed by the time no i don't
know i mean i know that for instance i
have two brothers they're younger
they're twins they're very fraternal
they're they're fraternal they don't
look alike they don't and they're more
different i'm more like either of them
than they are like each other i'm like
anyways one of them who's i think
brilliant he's got his own lab at uh
university of michigan now he's a
professor of um
deals with like heart cells and mice and
bio chemistry anyways um biomedical
research research anyway it's so smart
that you can't even decide i don't know
why but but it's also like my parents
say he's a genius i think so but it's
also a very learned language so it's
tough for me to
say i know he can speak that but he's
trained to do that but at the same time
i think he's quite accomplished like i
said he's got his own he's a professor
at the university of michigan so seems
pretty good anyways
he and the the broader point is he's
lovely now and a sweet guy and he was a
miserable bastard growing up and he was
so unhappy and he was always a good
student so he could turn it off at
school but he'd come home and
they hated each other these kids growing
up
it was just a war and and how far apart
were you having what was i'm five years
older so i was just like i'm not here
you know i'm not
like your kids weird yeah yeah
yeah
um but but anyways all to say my brother
at home anyways was a miserable son of a
[ __ ] who grew up to be a lovely person
and he was just i think he had a bit of
a chemical imbalance
maybe he's on the spectrum a little bit
i don't know you know all to say that i
see some of these kids and i think no it
might just be
you might grow out of this but there are
some kids and i've seen some things
where again we love the parents they're
lovely and i'm like i can't hang out
with you anymore or like i've just seen
kids like do mean [ __ ] like
this one girl like you know not even to
my daughter but they're all playing on
the jungle gym and she comes over and
one girl's hand is like she's climbing
up something and i see her just go and
step on it slowly
like just crush this girl's hand and and
a little sinister
yes sadistic
and the one thing i'll say
what i love one of the things i'm most
proud of of my daughter and i'm sure my
son's going to be the same way is like
she doesn't have that she doesn't have
any interest in causing pain and get any
pleasure out of that and that's good
it must be nice it must be nice but also
must be in a way such a relief because
i think about that sometimes and i i
would love to have kids but i think um
it is such a fear of mine that like you
said you have one who just happens to be
difficult and like not he looks and like
not a good
person that would be really
that'd be really hard um i really do
think there are ways to parent there are
ways we're more informed now than we
were a generation ago and there are ways
to combat that and redirect that i
should say and so i'm really curious
like
i think most
especially with nice parents but shown
the proper like channels to get their
feelings out will probably be sweet
people that must be really
hard to see somebody causing your kid
pain yeah it's untenable really i mean
you just gotta leave you know i've been
at friends houses i'm like i'm gonna
leave now because
you're not doing anything i don't say
this but it's like you're not doing
anything and your kid is only
trying to make my kid upset so when she
plays with something she's like you
can't play with that go you know or you
go on the trampoline i'm gonna shove you
i'm like i gotta go i don't know and so
then do you have to do that passive
aggressive thing where you're like
talking
to the kid now don't do that as some
version of like well no that's not yours
you have to share that but like kind of
also can you try to communicate with the
parents that's the
difficult part it's sort of i don't say
easy but like
i can talk to my kid but it's like when
you're parenting two a little bit or
trying to dispute and you want to
overstep but you also want to like
alleviate the situation
and um and fix the situation and that's
when it gets a little tricky and there's
only so much you can say to some other
kid that's not yours you know and and
try to explain to your kid without
hurting the other kid or their parent
you know by without throwing them under
the bus not your kid but i don't know it
gets a little tricky yeah quickly i do
want to talk about promising young women
because it's it's uh it's so good and i
your character was such a surprise
uh let has was the handyman here no i
looked uh let me let me just speak give
me yes yeah okay you have to go to the
restroom yes perfect see you back in
like three minutes okay perfect
hey cool
how was how was your p
quicking to the point
we can cut this out but are you finding
have you i remember a couple years ago
somebody said uh i was on the phone
while i was peeing i was on the phone
with them and they were like oh listen
to that he's this older broadway guy um
and he said oh wow
wow good for you and i was like what do
you mean
and he goes
your stream is
really powerful wonderful and i said um
it streams the stream it comes doesn't
it all come out the same he was like oh
god no you'll reach a point where it's
like you know it does you don't pee
this about a year ago and like
like i turned 42
and i was like my p i i'm like
sometimes peeing three times a night i'm
like i'm not probably have to go get my
prostate checked listeners are going to
love this yeah let's keep going no i'd
love to talk about this and you don't
have to cut this out i also
not three times a night but the
difference in p i've noticed for sure is
just the knight p like almost more often
than not i need a knight p
and then also and i think this has sort
of always been the case but i can't be
sure the stream's strong and good
but it doesn't matter
how many times i shake i could shake for
45 minutes there's a little a little bit
in my underwear yes
what is that why why didn't my dad tell
me about that ah why can't i just trick
my dick
all right
i know it's here in your underwear it's
gone look you shake shake shake shake
shake there's no more oh my god you know
that is so it's actually really um
it's really nice to hear you say that
yeah because i was like this is this i
guess it happens that's just what
happened yeah and i don't i can't say
for sure it didn't happen before but i
it's something i i noticed i don't
remember that yeah okay i guess i don't
either
speaking of peeing a little bit when you
think you're done
uh
promising young woman
um
your partner was so i i loved it because
it was and it's i i wonder if this is
why you did it it um it completely was a
play against what you
do so well it was what you what you've
you're kind of known to do is to pl you
play like such a great nice guy
um you play a guy you know where were
you at where were you in this movie i
know right i uh
um i know no but it was it was a real um
so so the turn was
was it as simple as that i want to do
that i want to i want to do that turn or
i just want to work with carrie yeah no
it was like it was a really good script
so you know like i'll do whatever
yeah um um there's really good script
and it's carrie mulligan and happy to be
involved in anyone that you want me to
and i had a great meeting with emerald
fennel who's just lovely and charming oh
what a great director what i love the
movie i also love her name
emerald fennel i know yeah
yeah
and she's like
really talented actor too
i know that you know and it's we're
getting to that point too where like
directors are becoming younger than us
and uh that's weird i know um i know
they pee better hey p stronger cleaner
so yeah that's why and i do think it's a
wise use of myself and
other actors in it as well kind of um
subverting our
um personas so it's wise and it was fun
because you know you know that the
audience is the first stuff's easy you
pretend to be charming you think you're
trying you know he thinks he's charming
the whole time but where it really gets
fun
is making the audience squirm later
where she's more or less a corpse and
he's you know being dashing to her and
putting the moves on and it gets
gross and gross and playing with that
line normally it's like you know it's
very clear it's like oh this guy's a
douchebag or there's a very clear turn
where whereas this is um it's a lot more
subtle and uh it's disturbing how real
it's all played you know honestly one of
the easier parts quite honestly i'm sure
you would recognize that too because
it's like well you start out you're just
a regular guy you're charming and then
you don't have to you know so much of
our jobs are like trying to make a
character likeable even if they're not
that likable on the page or some of
their
dialogue or actions are questionable
you're like how do i like make this
palatable and make him a hero to this to
be able to be uh liberated from that and
lean into everything
that's awful about it and at the same
time not have the burden of i'm playing
a super comedic douche and i gotta come
up with like very funny stuff to make
you know um this guy on the cell phone
or that such an [ __ ] you know such an
ass wife it just is very natural almost
subtle stuff that's just awful and funny
in the grounded context that's true that
makes sense yeah i'm thinking now of
some of the um
which is why it's fun to do the kevin
smith things because you just get to
you don't have to worry about that so
you get to kind of play and do whatever
you need to play but with the kevin
smith stuff the difference is i mean
that's what i'm thinking of i've played
like you know [ __ ] and his stuff and
it's like
you got to it's fun because it's it's
freeing and it's fun but you also have
to come with your own jokes and like do
it at like a 12 and like bring a lot of
you know and this is like you don't have
it's all on the page and you can be very
subtle and take it easy and i didn't
have a lot of heavy lifting it was
pretty crazy is that what you're doing
because i was like uh is that what
you're doing you're doing press now for
that you're no uh the kid detective the
kid detective is what i'm oh
it's okay
well let's talk about that
uh oh the kid detective
what is that well tell me i'll tell you
all about it well
it's this passion project of mine that
uh a super talented writer director
approached me with like eight years ago
and we have been trying to get it made i
sort of never thought it would after a
watch i tried getting it for a while and
i was like not going to happen and then
lo and behold it did
filmed it you know 2019 end of 2019
um and it is a uh i just love it it's
sort of my the most satisfying
movie or really of my career partly
because i had i also produced it and i
have a lot of
you know i made a lot of creative
decisions not just acting in it but also
it was written for me and more than that
i just love it it's like
it's about
a former kid detective prodigy
encyclopedia brown
uh uh nancy drew what have you
who um
gets hung up on uh you know solving
petty crimes in this town and he
celebrated and then
and then um when he's 12 his secretary
who's also his age 13 year old girl goes
missing
it really [ __ ] him up he can't solve it
and um um 20 years later he's the town
drunk and he's still um and he's still
solving like missing cat stuff and
then a high school girl
asks him to solve her boyfriend's murder
and so he's got a big case chance to
prove himself he's horribly unequipped
but
while it is a silly and very
commercial
premise
and it is a has a bunch of comedy in it
it's way more grounded and psychological
than you would think
my friend is such a talented writer i
mean it just has what it really has is
like
a script full of
quotable dialogue it's the kind of
script that like
he's not in hollywood otherwise like
it's such a blacklist script to me you
know
that like
should have won or been high on the
blacklist
is your friend from school from back no
he's he's toronto based and i met him at
a film festival like eight years ago and
he's become a good friend but um um
yeah he doesn't really have many
connections to the business but anyways
it's awe it's it's it's just it's a good
it's a really good movie i'm really
proud of it yeah now i really want to
see this how where do people see it
it got released in the true sense of the
word kind of dumped here it is it's on
the [ __ ] internet it didn't get
buried but it certainly got dumped
yeah and um you know
that's okay because people are finding
it and i'm promoting it and like not
that anyone would see it in the height
of the pandemic abandoned years across
america but it did allow us to get
reviewed from a lot of places help build
awareness for a digital release that
then happened in late january um i can't
wait okay kid detective check it out we
will um and we'll post about it that's
the nice thing about social media right
too you can like if there's been some
deficiency in something that you care
about people wanting people to see you
can um
put it out there yeah yeah i know it's
it's been nice and we have been and i
can even see
more or less who sees it oh really you
know that's true
um so if you don't see it adam will know
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
this segment is brought to you by bud
light seltzer's new retro summer pack
christian yes where were you during
the oj chase i remember where i was when
that happened do you the white ford
bronco yeah where were you i was
sitting on my butt watching
the uh nba finals the knicks were
playing the nba finals against the
rockets and they cut away from the game
to show
the car chase so you must have been
immediately intrigued by the car going
down the highway with police chasing it
no i was immediately frustrated i'm
kidding so many so many fun memories oh
yeah of summer time summer
the fireworks fireworks at the beach i
miss the fireworks but guess what we
also like um modern day good vibes right
yeah i love good vibes at any time of
the day or if this sees any seasonal
vibe but you know do you know what helps
facilitate the good vibes i do most
importantly you want some bud light
seltzer nearby yes and
the type of bud light seltzer you should
get for the best vibes
is the new limited edition bud light
seltzer retro summer pack so the new tie
dye pack features three throwback
flavors that are reminiscent of the
summers we're talking about i'm not even
looking at the flavors but i would say
what would spark some memories for me in
terms of flavors would be like i don't
know summer ice that's one of them
really yes oh i'm thinking not raspberry
but like a different it's a color of
raspberry yes one that it doesn't come
in absolutely blue raspberry yeah
there's that one oh well try to guess
the third one okay well not just cherry
flavor i would add it with like
not a lemonade but something in the
citrus aid family maybe like a cherry
you're so close cherry limeade yes is
that it yep oh my god
well if that weren't exciting enough for
the first time ever fans could also
purchase these out of sight flavors in a
new form what kind of flavors out of
sight with bud light seltzer retro
summer icicles
so grab some friends play some tunes and
enjoy the vibes so get it delivered
right to your door
find a retailer near you at budlight.com
delivery or
pick it up yourself support local
business at the local grocery store or
convenience store liquor store
hello hello
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say it's embarrassing but the
the shaka emoji
oh yeah yeah
yeah that's
what
well surfing that's yours for a [ __ ]
turf dork and it's funny it's like just
in the last handful of years i kind of
quit for all my 20s and even half of my
30s and then i picked it back up and now
it's a huge part of my life but i almost
feel like i'm doing press for it now now
it's like i
i've been you know just organically
talking about it a lot and then
um
i don't know i'm getting embarrassed
again
if you could be a professional athlete
would it be a surfer oh yeah i'm not
thinking of joey kern i'm thinking of
you in grind have you talked to joey in
a while have you
i have i did a movie that joey wrote and
directed like probably oh my god that's
right
oh you're great in that i like that
movie thanks yeah he did he did a really
good job
yes big bear which i don't know if you
know this
is loosely based on
something that i'm kind of responsible
for so are you well i i take it you know
he's he's him he's playing himself but
then you are you me am i playing you
no i'm uh
no i'm the one i don't think i'm
represented in it because i'm the one
that set him up with okay okay yeah
not really my fault i wasn't like hey i
didn't go out of my way to do it and
then they stayed off for a while
oh like immediately and and i was very
proud
i was very proud of it and i remember
seeing her at um i mean it happened like
that right
but i remember seeing her out and i was
like so it's coming up and she's like
yeah because i've gotten this email
whatever um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life your your your goat
your stoned your go-to snack food i mean
i love it it's not i wouldn't call it a
snack food exactly but
i mean i love a donut
okay
and i'll tell you this i love the high
end you know there's they're doing all
the high-end ones now and that's great
it's the same as like burger you know
fries too it's like i love a good
high-class fry but it's still hard to
beat mcdonald's and for me as much as i
like
sidecar and blue star and all the the
artisan artisanal donuts yeah i i don't
like duncan sucks but like your local
car dealership has like some great ones
still it may be my favorite
you're in the land of great strip mall
oh yeah don't drip donut not the big
your strip mall average trip mall donut
that's not doing anything fancy is as
good to me as any other fan
what's your favorite movie sequel of all
time from raider too
yeah
ah
those two are like what are the what's
the opposite of oil and water
salt and pepper peanut butter
peanut butter and jelly i mean it's like
yeah those are so amazing it's such a
it's such a great idea an advancement
and flip the flip side of the coin of
the first movie i mean it uh yeah and
they both hold up remarkably well i
think like s side terminator not real
[ __ ] if i made that grass real fast yeah
i can't figure out the time travel [ __ ]
and all the i know they've been trying
to reboot it for a million years and
there's a million ways and i don't know
how to
i couldn't get into the the um minutiae
of the timelines and the whatever but
one thing i think that they would
could do
is the first two are like westerns and
they're simple and they take place in la
in a day and then there's like one guy
that's a monster and the others are like
star trek that's true there's this whole
universe yes and we're in the future and
we're in the past and there's a million
aliens and it's like if you could get
back to the simplicity of like the real
world and one [ __ ] robot walking
around oh my god some appeal to me
oh my god adam i feel that way about so
many i don't know if this means we're
getting older or if this is just a truth
about entertainment but i feel that way
about comedy i feel that way but when i
watch seinfeld it's like they're they
just are waiting for a table at a
chinese restaurant or they need to get a
rye bread up to there's something
beautiful and and so much easier to
digest about uh a story like that um the
simplicity of it maybe it's the ocd in
me i guess but i'm obsessed with economy
in everything in storytelling movement
and sports and but
in screenplays you know i love
the tight screenplay and i love you know
um
and how much can you do with how little
and and and just um ratcheting the
tension and getting um all the fat out
and obviously you can go on tangents but
i do not understand
the need now for the 10th movie it's a
prerequisite like it's got to be two
hours and 30 minutes this is what eight
girls want it's gonna be two hours and
30 minutes and if there's an action
scene and you've got a few ideas make it
a 20 minute action scene and just and
and run out of ideas and just have it
devolve into white noise quickly
it's been it's so bananas to me i'm like
what what happened to the 90 like why
are your kids movies why are they not an
hour and 40 minutes
and i thought it's what you know it was
one of my favorite things what i think
people responded to in shazam was the
simplicity of it it's not very bloated
it's funny i thought you were going to
say maybe it's the oc in me and then you
added a letter
what is your go-to karaoke song
uh i have a very shitty voice and
limited range within that that the [ __ ]
vocal so i guess it's changing but i
keep it low weirdly though i can i guess
harry nilsson everybody's talking that's
a fun one that i can kind of do that
doesn't blow me out yeah do you do the
wow
wow yeah yeah that's fun
hey that was good you don't have a
shitty voice
who is your very first celebrity crush
well
i i'm sure i can i can recall many
um
yeah if there's a way to narrow it down
to ten yeah yeah
i'm trying to think of the first first
first like yeah like the formative one i
mean because i can yeah it's like i
could think of all
trying to think and i just you know i
just want it to be i just want this to
be special justin no i know
i know but you want to be respectful
i could rifle off like uh i know i pull
off no uh that's not the term but um
you know i could say carrie green in
goonies or i could say meredith salinger
and dream a little dream or
heather graham and license or drive but
i'm not going to do that i want to think
of because you want to respect the one
stumped i don't know were you a big star
wars guy not real yes average average
and it hasn't stayed with me in a like
i'm not a big one now can i guess the
butt can i guess the butt that you were
gonna say yeah but
in return of the jedi we were
five four or five yeah uh we started did
you see it in the theaters i don't
remember well i remember i think that
was probably the first time i saw
somebody like that wearing somebody like
something like that
now here's my butt
okay everyone always talks about the
gold bikini no one ever mentions that
she's [ __ ] chained up yeah right
interesting
i i hadn't noticed that adam um you know
i mean yeah it's like the you know i
guess it's like the feyre whoever played
in king kong you know what i mean yeah
she's also like captive and there's
something um
yeah i don't know primal about that i
think too if he was just walking in a
bikini it might not have had the same
effect
i started being chained to
bob that needed rescuing that's true and
somebody that you knew
you were more appealing i mean i i knew
at five that i was more appealing than
job the highest yeah and and and needed
wrestling and needed a need desperately
in need of a hero
yes although you know i think she sort
of saved herself by strangling him as
well so she was that's true
you know
she had independence she was yeah but
you know there's something to that
yeah
yeah i don't want to dig too deep but um
also i think king kong has been canceled
um
well well if it comes to you if there's
somebody because now i'm thinking it's
tough because they're
during that time um i'm thinking we
probably have similar touchstones uh
and you don't want to say too many
because it's like oh jesus calm down
yeah well i'll tell you i don't know if
you ever see
uh this is also meredith salander from
dreamily dream but uh art um a night in
the life of jimmy weirdon oh my god
river phoenix wait wait don't tell me uh
don't tell me it was um yes it yeah you
gotta tell me no no it was um
she's the queen in there
we couldn't watch our rated movies my
parents were pretty strict about
that i could literally walk down the
street at eight and rent all the already
movies i want by myself from the from
the local video store i don't know why
but
um
latch key kid and uh
samantha mathis problem of the volume
who was who was the night in the life of
jimmy reardon besides well it's her and
i only know because i literally haven't
seen it yet but it's under a different
name now because it's the director's cut
and maybe they wanted he wanted a
different title i haven't seen it since
i was 10. because i wanted to like be
river phoenix when i was young oh and um
yeah and then lastly i was in love with
every girl in days
oh i was like oh my god this high school
yeah
michelle burke that was my favorite
which one she
michelle burke is the one they go in the
woods she goes in the woods with jason
london but she said i'll never forget
this line where she says i love the way
she said it she goes the professor is
sexy
remember they're talking about uh
gilligan's island
michelle burke she was in coneheads
yes funny enough i kind of i didn't
think so as much on my rewatch or like
my i haven't really watched that movie
but like i dipped my tone was on tv not
too long ago but previous to that i was
sort of under the assumption she looked
a lot like late
yes and then i still see that but when i
saw it again structures it's not as
um
yeah
it's not as much as i thought but i i
had it in my head that she was uh
yeah yeah no who was yeah the whole cast
yeah
uh yeah there's like um
i don't know there's like a 10 year old
uh mila jovovich is in it yeah
yeah who's playing that cool song also a
girl who could play the guitar and smoke
a joint
uh
yeah all right well
now we're both getting weird uh if you
had to get a uh
you had to do you have tattoos do you
have any tattoos i don't have any
tattoos you have any tattoos you don't i
don't um i hesitated because i had one
once and it's since faded it was like a
i got drunk and somebody did a stick and
poke um
uh but if you had to get one what would
you get something of
the family i guess you know it's the
only thing i can see like meaning enough
but i've never even like been tempted
i've never gone like
and i feel like the ship has sailed and
you know well while i think they look
cool i think they can look cool and and
in general i think a lot of them look
cooler than a few or i don't know it
everyone's different and i i do think
they look cool but on me i've never been
tempted and then it's hard for me to
fathom the one i think was
cool looking and would continue to think
was you know neat but i wouldn't like
it's not a hard rule i mean if i was
inspired and
late in the other day my daughter drew
something a little heart with like all
her family's names in it and she's like
i wouldn't get another tattoo but if i
did this would be it and i'm like wow
that's a good call that would be that
would be a nice tattoo that's the only
kind of thing i could see but um
and what is your favorite fruit what a
good great question i
i love them all but i guess
like a perfect plum like a plum that's
just
right you know
right there sour and sweet i've been
eating those blue oats a lot i think
they're called they're like the green
plum oh yeah the green ones yeah those
are great too
oh wow i haven't had a good plum in a
long time
um
who would you want to play you in a
biopic in your biopsy
i guess you
wow
i i'm flattered i would like that
uh
yeah i can see i'm thinking now coming
to la for the first time yeah yeah i
mean if it depends what you know if it's
got a spammer it starts earlier
i don't know
i would want you to play me yeah yeah
i wouldn't
okay okay well trade we'll try biopic
parts um
who's your favorite simpsons character
and if it's homer or who's your favorite
like secondary one yeah uh
i mean i remember i guess not anymore
and i've
while i respect the hell out of the
simpsons i can't imagine being one of
the people who's like been watching it
for 40 years but
certainly it's been a while it's so
weird but i've been certainly i was
super into it
at the time and my first pair of boxer
shorts this is in like the middle of the
elementary school my first pair of boxer
shorts ever this is when you wore like
just whitey tighties
i didn't know they even went under and
so they're bart simpson and i just
thought they were shorts and i wore them
over my underwear too full actually
that's funny oh yeah anything
parkinson's
i'm sure he was saying
or something
um
don't have a cow man
do you say whitey tighties or tighty
whites oh i don't know i guess i don't
know what i just said and in general oh
you said whitey tighty whitey tighties
i don't know
did you switch full then did you because
i tried boxer shorts i thought that was
like the mature thing to do um i thought
that's when you were in high school
that's i remember my brother
and i hated him uh
did you ever adopt that boxer i was yeah
yeah i know then it was boxer shorts
all through my
teens and most of my
20s and then settled on for life now
clearly the answer is boxer briefs boxer
briefs yeah duh okay you can definitely
play me then um
uh
dogs uh dogs are cats i like both but
but dogs do you have any you guessed
something i we did we did all deceased
no i'm sorry but we'll we'll uh we'll
we'll grab another one soon enough the
beatles for the rolling stones beetles
yeah if i can do everything they did
post beetle
but i'm totally i've taken advantage of
your your your time i could do
would be great to hang out properly one
of these days and loved you thanks buddy
i'm bad
so happy for that family what an
adorable oh thanks
yeah we're um it's pretty great it's
pretty great it's great if you love your
kids
you're you're lucky you're you're doing
it um and best of leighton okay i'll
tell you she says hello as well yeah
she's always going very very highly
she's the best she's great uh and and so
was this i really i truly appreciate
your time man oh hey thanks sam sam
[Music]
california
oh man so i haven't heard that song in a
while that that just happened yeah it's
a little bit like um it's a little jonah
yeah it's a little jonah yeah well
jonah's become a surfer he sure has he's
really embracing that culture he looks
like a really good surfer based on the
pictures oh man i would like to go
surfing with jonah you have gone surfing
haven't you i have but not with jonah
but
didn't you kind of take to search i did
i had a moment i had a moment that see
jonah stuck with it i did not um
it it doesn't help living out here it's
hard to surf on the east coast that's my
excuse i remember when you didn't you
tried in mac uh hawaii sayalita is the
first time i did it in mexico and it was
what a perfect place to do because the
waves were kind of easy there were
smaller waves and uh there weren't a lot
of people judging me because it's not a
big surf club but i do remember i think
you're you're being a little too humble
because a little too modest because i
remember being very impressed by how
quickly you took to it well you know why
you were good like right away well that
was about 10 years ago would you say we
went to that trip yeah maybe a little
more a couple years ago i guess two
years ago now right year before the
pandemic i went to nicaragua i took my
annual trip to nicaragua the girls home
girls home thegirlshome.com if you want
to check out what we do there it's a
great place um shout out yes and i went
with my my friend rachel and drew also
shout out and we stopped at a great
surfing spot in nicaragua on the coast i
was a little uh confident about i wasn't
not it wasn't jessica rabbit feet level
but i was like pretty confident about my
surfing skills there was some hubris
yo yeah there sure was i couldn't get up
on the board and they were watching me
it was extra embarrassing because i they
took time out of their schedule because
they took me to the spot they're like
wow if you like surfing so i went out
there for like i said i'll catch a few
waves half hour and they were watching
me on the beach and i i couldn't get up
on the board it was so embarrassing uh
you know adam brody you guys have shared
a similar space
in the industry so yeah
roughly the same age you came up the
same time the more you were talking with
him the more i realized how many
similarities you do have yes i never put
that together that you i knew you did
this but the vince vaughn thing his his
admiration of vince vaughn how much he
looks up to him and how she's sort of
modeled
his acting career yes
like you i would say yes um for sure
you're both you both uh know leighton
meester that's another uh similarity yes
you both um pee in your underwear after
you finish going to the bathroom you
know i gotta say i've gotten better at
that i don't really do that as much and
i think it's because um i'm trying to
figure out what i attribute it to but uh
it's not for whatever reason is my
diamond i'm sleeping more maybe i'm more
confident maybe your prostate is
strengthening somehow well have it
happen i don't know i feel prostate
confidence ever since i got that check
from
my doctor whose name i won't mention but
yeah i got the old finger check and um i
talked about it on the show and not
ashamed of it but it you know it is a
really you feel better about like okay
well maybe so maybe a lot of it was
psychosomatic the dribble
because i don't get any more dribble
yeah
do you have never get that you you
haven't noticed any difference in your
peeing yeah a little bit like the on off
isn't quite as yeah yeah it takes longer
to finish it does yep but i don't always
have a post p dribble like you guys do
but maybe i will you know i'm i'm
approaching 40. you yeah you guys are a
little older than i am i wonder if this
had any effect on my peeing is because i
i've been driving a lot i've been like
going on these long trips i went drove
the van from arkansas and
you know it's hard to especially when
you're drinking coffee it's hard to time
out the peas and you don't want to stop
too often
you have a very sensitive bladder you
think you say that but i i do i guess i
do you do
it fills up pretty quickly any time i've
been on a road trip i'm you're always
always the first one to be like can we
pull over that's annoying it's okay i
can pee in the van you have a tiny
bladder or maybe you're just sensitive
you're triggered by um caffeine more
than other people i don't know you know
what you know what math i'm doing in my
head
are people gonna care about this at all
anyone i mean some people yeah some
people will urologists
um or they won't they won't want to hear
about this if i were a urologist the
last thing i want to do is put on a
podcast with
one of my favorite uh podcasting teams
i'll tell you what
no one's going to care that i haven't
had this problem yet in my life there is
going to be a handful of people who are
interested in in what happens to you and
up
i can't imagine anybody being interested
in what happens when i have you repeat
your pants
yeah
how long when was the last time um
the last time i remember it i was very i
remember because it was very
embarrassing i was at a sleepover party
when i was i think in
fifth grade oh
oh mine is much more embarrassing it was
more recent i was like two nights ago uh
a couple years ago i was driving back
from 4100 shout out i don't know if it's
still there i think it is oh it is yeah
our friend diana shout out was the
bartender and um i i had a drink but not
out i hadn't been drinking alcohol
really but i was like i just had to pee
and i was going down the bars had let
out so i was two in the morning i'm
going down sunset looking for a place to
pee
it was emergency so i pulled over in
west hollywood
off of sunset and i there was a one of
those little dead end things and um i
got out to pee and a cop
he didn't pull me over but pulled up
with his lights on right in front of me
and i was like
walk back in the car and you know once
psychologically you make the choice to
like yeah oh it's i'm gonna release it
now it's ready it's like the couch is
open there's exactly there's no turning
back and so i gotta you don't wanna get
a pui
no like
former friend of the show you know
we don't have to say it is but it's
really funny memory a friend of ours has
got to be
a pu of a uip urinating public and um so
i got back i was actually thinking about
him and um and i got as i was driving
down sunset grabbed some bad i had a bag
fortunately a garbage bag from the back
seat uh sat on it uh sat atop it and
just made it's the weirdest thing to
make the choice because it was
too late you had no bottles or anything
no no i thought about but bottles too
when you think because i thought about
this on the road trip a bottle the
mechanics of going in a bottle while
you're driving is really dangerous and
difficult to get in a lot of bottles
while you're driving uh no but while
exactly while the car was driving yeah
that's different you you can move around
more and when you're driving you can't
get it
it's
to get it in the hole and the whole
thing you know what i recommend
bottle-wise a large gatorade bottle
because it's a wide mouth your penis has
plenty of room not for everyone's but uh
yes for most people i would say so your
opinions had plenty of room not plenty
of room
but room to
fit in the top it wasn't snug
it was not snug
all right um so adam brody yeah yeah
speaking of
um can probably fit in i bet he's
peter's pants at some point i wonder i
should have asked him
um i bet they have some cute kids oh
adorable
she's beautiful obviously and he is too
he's a such attractive couple yeah and
it's great that not only do they have
attractive kids more importantly sounds
like they have nice kids yeah exactly
and you know there's a lot of not nice
kids out there as you guys talk to yeah
especially attractive kids content
i don't want to generalize you don't
know what shiloh jolie picked like
that's true that's true we should get
him on a little gentleman
on the show uh you know i'm now thinking
just purely superficially about the two
of them and i i am hard-pressed to come
up with some kind of combination where
the kids wouldn't be attracted how could
those two
[Music]
produce anything but like really
adorable kids that's true because
sometimes you know sometimes there's a
couple where i know it's like
combination here's an example don't that
might be mean no i won't i think i'm
saying as a person no as a person i'm
saying like tom cruise for example is
obviously
extremely handsome but
it's everything kind of works together
but not each one of his features is like
the ideal version of a feature right you
know what i mean i know what you mean so
if that's combined with a different gene
pool it might not work out you're right
you're right you know but like obviously
for tom cruise it works you're right
amazing but then when you think about
adam but those two are likely they all
have they
all their features are kind of i know
like adam would i bet would be a really
pretty woman in drag more importantly
nice kids no i i know i know i should we
shouldn't dwell on the superficial no
it's great that they're nice it's the
best it's really admirable that they are
especially since you know they they grow
up they're growing up in a privileged
home and i think you got to work a
little bit harder to make to
combat that speaking of
superficial things he's totally right
about days confused and the girls in
that i remember seeing that movie the
first time when i was in eighth grade oh
man you know eighth grade no it's uh
you don't think about much else during
that year no you don't and i remember
being like oh my god this is what it's
like yeah this is what high school is
going to be like and then it's like fast
forward a year i'm at an all boys school
and
like nothing close to that experience
yeah there were some uh slaters at prep
slater sun yeah there were there were a
couple like because that was simple we
went to high school during a time where
um
the 70s actually movies like days and
fews were popular and like the 70s in
general were being
coming back you remember that
i thought you had a crazy brain fart and
i thought you thought we were we were in
the 70s no
uh
no yeah it came back a little bit but
our high school
a dress code when we had remember the
rules you couldn't have your hair below
your shoulders yes but kids like they
pushed they pushed the envelope and like
i remember them especially the rich kids
would go out to the parking lot and they
had like cool they could like they knew
exactly how to push the envelope and
they were into like the dead and like
you know fish was really popular fish
wasn't in dave matthews band yeah maybe
future guest one of the nicest human
beings i've ever met really yes
incredibly nice i think more people are
gonna care about that than you peeing in
your pants you do yeah he's nice yeah i
don't know anyway so he was nice yeah
very very nice did you just start to
sing his song yeah i just looked over at
you and you go crash into me
i love that song i went on a whole album
oh my god but that's also
i mean i'm talking about today yeah yeah
that was like that was alright are you
getting a little turned on thinking
about it not turned on yeah but
nostalgic and happy yeah and that way i
meant yeah not not sexually okay you got
your hands down your pants it's on my um
waistband why do you have it in there
are you cold no but it's comfortable i
like wearing pockets and you don't have
pockets um i do but these pockets aren't
great for for that's hard to explain
these are like meshy pockets i'll say
this of the dave matthews thing the
peeing the pants thing and this this is
probably
in terms of people caring
yeah definitely the least
no one cares that i like pockets
i bet i bet our mother wouldn't even
care
um adam brody is right about the perfect
plum oh yeah i know it's been a long
time since i've had a perfect plum yeah
but they're really hard to be when you
get that snap on the outside and they're
and they're really juicy and sweet and a
little he says it yeah a little sour
yeah and what's that tart tart is sweet
yes a plut it's a plum and an apricot
mixed together right yeah bread together
those are delicious um do you want to
read a letter sure
uh here's dustin hoffman singing that
song california
california
here we come okay
from fb
beth b subject would you rather great hi
christian and justin long time listener
not first time writing in so i'll skip
how much i love the podcast and get
right to the good stuff well what if
that's the good stuff yeah it depends
yeah it's about good stuff to us no i um
that's nice you to listen and to be
writing in so does that mean she wrote
good stuff on earlier letters i guess in
earlier letters i i wish i knew what she
had i know me too bath well i'm guessing
she likes the show she's a longtime
listener um okay back to beth i love
that someone adam corolla finally said
that live free or die hard was their
favorite movie sequel i can't believe no
one has yet oh this is good stuff uh not
just because you are the one asking the
question and you're in it but also
because it is one of the best movie
sequels of all time it's one of the few
sequels that is as good as bordering on
better than the original wow
you know i think it's really good i
think it's good i don't agree with that
i i think the original is just a
masterpiece
but that i it's very nice to hear that
because god we worked hard on it i will
say that i think
proud of it
your die hard movie is the best
sequel of die hards yeah
five there's five i didn't see the fifth
one
okay back to beth thank you beth uh the
and i'm sure if len wiseman's listening
the director of the movie he would thank
you too
friend of mine the only other one that
comes to mind that's better than the
original is bill and ted's bogus journey
hmm
yeah i haven't seen that in a long time
either we saw the third one not too long
ago and uh
it's not as good as the originals uh i
also hesitated to say the third one's
not i i
didn't
like it nearly as much as the first one
but uh my my first movie director dean
pariso directed it so uh dean is a
incredible director one of the best um
okay who cares also i found back to bed
also i finally have a good would you
rather all right
would you rather have none of your
clothes aft this is so weird what
listen to this this is so weird
would you rather have none of your
clothes have any pockets oh weird it's
not weird not even your jackets or have
one large pocket but it is front and
center on all your pants opens at the
top is so large you have to fumble
around in it to find things it's like a
fanny pack like a built into like a
kangaroo patch yeah yeah like a pouch
pouch and when you do find things that
uh when you do that it definitely looks
like you are pleasuring yourself and no
pockets on any of your other clothes um
well i think you know my answer yeah so
uh i would rather have that one big
pocket well
but the one
obvious
caveat is
that you have to you don't if you can't
make it look like you're not pleasuring
yourself no no no i think that's just
she's saying that's a potential
byproduct okay but if if she's saying
um that every time that's part of the
deal that's part of the hypothetical
that it definitely looks like you're
pleasuring her i don't think so that's
well i'd have to reconsider my answer uh
she's just it's so large you have to
fumble around in it to find things and
when you do that it def and when you do
that it definitely looks like you're
pleasuring yourself okay well that's a
problem
cause if every time you go into your
pocket in public it legitimately looks
like you're pleasuring yourself just
turn away from people
okay you know just don't do it on like
playgrounds or just get
better at making it not look like that i
guess yeah yeah that that's the tricky
one because it's like you can also keep
fewer things in the pocket i would
definitely pick the big pocket i know
but now that i'm thinking about it
yeah i guess why not in fact
you get both hands in there oh yeah rest
sounds comfortable it does i like that
being able to do that right i like you
know the way cowboys do it like they
kind of like
rest their hands and their thumbs yeah
i like you sometimes i'll do it i'll get
so lazy that i'll do it like this with
my collar on my shirt i'll hold i'll
hold on to my collar like this if i
don't have pockets does that mean we're
insecure that we need to do stuff with
their hands oh um
maybe
can't you just remember being in place
in high school yes and you're always
still aware of your hands yeah knowing
what to do with your hands that's often
a tell of an actor of an insecure actor
a self-conscious actor you see that
they're like struggling with their hands
that's often where it you know manifests
but yeah you pick the pocket i think i'd
pick the pocket yeah although now that i
think about it it'd be a good exercise
to not but i like keeping things what do
i do with my money and here's the
problem if i don't have pockets
one big pocket or normal pockets i might
end up resting my hands
on your waistband and my pants a lot and
then that could be problematic as as
i've just noticed it looks like you got
your hands down right yeah
but if they're not moving how it does
it's not going to look like you're
pleasuring yourself who cares if your
hands just down your pant a little i
think people would care well they care
but it's i'm saying it's like it's not
obvious it doesn't look like you're
doing anything no i know but it's still
like not a clean looking thing
occasionally i have to adjust you know
and i'll i'll you know you got to check
to make sure no one's around but i'll
i'll have to do it well i often when i
do adjust i often and i'm in public and
i have to adjust i often try to do it
through my pocket
yes
yeah but that looks that can look weird
i think i know i'm pretty good at it
okay all right thank you beth um it's
good would you rather it is good and uh
thanks for that and very appropriate
considering how weird and if you guys
would like to write in our email address
is life is short at wondery.com and
thank you to our
very charming guest adam brody and uh
all of the listeners yeah and go check
out his movie oh yeah he's got excellent
reviews that kid detective where is it
it's on netflix it's streaming streaming
you'll find it and um if you haven't
seen promising young woman oh man we
both highly recommend it
so take that for what it's worth yeah um
and uh we also recommend that you uh
listen to the voice memo at the end of
this if you want and we also recommend
um you tuning in next week uh thanks to
everyone who makes the show possible and
we're gonna
name them right now
[Music]
follow life is short on apple podcasts
amazon music the wondery app or wherever
you're listening right now listen ad
free by joining wondery plus if you like
our show please give us a five star
rating and a review and be sure to tell
your friends another way you can support
the shows by filling out a small survey
at
survey life is wonderee.com
is hosted by me
justin long it is co-hosted and produced
by you christian long it's also produced
by megan v monaco senior producer
michelle miesh land audio engineer
sergio enriquez and there's an executive
producer whose parents one day long time
ago named him marshall louis
for a company called wondering
bye everyone
[Music]
the following is not a paid ad for honey
mamas
it's just a company we love and a voice
member we thought was funny
what's that one it's not about ginger
really
[Laughter]
it's really cardamom
well
can i try it um i'm saying
this okay
let me like speculate while i'm like in
the middle of my first fight
[Applause]
really you like it better than coconuts
not necessarily just very interesting
well
it's like there's like a bouquet of
chocolate flowers my man
you know isn't it very floral
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wundery app
[Music]